don't want to abandon them do you and
sean to know how this could all end
though this would all go out if it's
going to go out yeah we definitely talk
about yes yes for sure shonda is the
queen and
we we we do have to run big decisions by
her for sure oh you are definitely not
going back to seattle could there be a
future at grey's anatomy without
meredith that's not for me to decide
it's not my show in that way
um that would be someone else's decision
entirely whether there will be a season
19 with ellen remains to be seen but
devoted fans have been devouring the
return of the og cast members you gave
me permission to go it started last
season with patrick dempsey and
continues this thursday with kate walsh
i'm dr addison montgomery what can you
tell us about addison's return to the
orbit
we are doing a surgery together so she
is
addison montgomery is presented with a
super challenging surgery
and she needs some help get me meredith
gray kate and i had a great time working
together the original cast we have such
a intense bond because we went through
something so intense together scott's
back too scott speedman scott speedman
is back love him still not sleeping with
you
that's possibly the nicest thing
anyone's ever said to me
and meredith is flirting around with
nick is he viable though i mean is he
really viable for meredith
what yeah what are you okay
okay
okay
that cast bond transcends into her new
podcast tell me with ellen pompeo
available wherever you get your podcast
you start to look at the good the bad
and the ugly we've all come through it
with a tremendous amount of forgiveness
and love for each other you did have
patrick on of course patrick dempsey do
you plan on having anybody else from
grace yeah well i i do i definitely um i
had eric jane yesterday we have like we
had a fun conversation eric and i are
very close we hang out all the time kate
walsh lives in australia now so the
timing's been a little challenging
but yeah i always you know i love my
greatest family and um they'll always be
people from grace on the podcast for
sure how do you determine like i am
gonna say this i'm not gonna say this on
the podcast
well i i definitely have an edit button
and i you know i've already gotten into
some trouble i realized how powerful my
voice has the potential to be and i do
feel a responsibility to give back in
some way i've chosen this as one of them
i'm terrified to be honest when i speak
i'm always afraid that i'm going to say
something that someone might be able to
take peace out of
context
and plaster it somewhere and make me
sound like someone who i'm not yeah and
i can't really control that if you hear
the conversations and if you spend any
time looking at anything i put out i
generally try to be super positive and
leave with love all the time
[Music]
you